[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez vous vous promenez dans la
campagne par une belle soirée d'hiver
tous vos sens sont aiguisés par le froid
et vous vous émerveiller de petites
perception le scintillement de la glace
dans les arbres la neige qui crissent
sous vos pieds et vous vous demandez est
ce que c'est vraiment possible que
chacune de ces perceptions soit le
résultat des calculs des neurones de mon
cerveau est ce que je peux croire à
cette théorie
telle est l'hypothèse extraordinaire qui
nous est proposé aujourd'hui par les
neurosciences
chacune de nos perceptions chacun de nos
états conscient est un état d'activités
de notre cerveau et nous pouvons
commencer à les décoder par les méthodes
des neurosciences c'est cette
exploration du cerveau qui est une
aventure extraordinaire de la fin du
xxème siècle de ceux de notre siècle du
xxème siècle que je voudrais vous
raconter aujourd'hui une aventure qui
est rendue possible par des avancées
étonnant de l'imagerie cérébrale
l'idée très ancienne que l'âme l'esprit
est différente du corps nous la
retrouvons peut-être déjà dans cette
gravure que vous trouverez tout au bout
de la grotte de lascaux c'est l'idée que
dans le rêve
nous nous échappons mentalement notre
esprit peut s'envoler alors que le corps
est inerte
nous nous envolons vers des paysages
lointains vers des personnes que
peut-être nous n'avons pas rencontré
depuis très longtemps qu'ils sont
peut-être morte mais que nous pouvons
retrouver en rêve et c'est peut-être
cette idée qui est déjà illustré ici
dans cette scène depuis de lascaux voyez
une personne qui est allongée bon c'est
clairement un homme je crois que c'est
clair et vous voyez est en érection
il est allongé c'est typique du sommeil
paradoxal et peut-être cet homme est il
en train de rêver peut-être la première
représentation d'un état de rêve
il rêve qu'il est en train de chasser et
qu'il a réussi à blesser un bison on
voit les tripes du bison qui sont en
train de s'échapper ici et à côté de lui
vous voyez il ya un oiseau cet homme a
une tête d'oiseau dans toutes les
cultures
l'oiseau représente l'esprit l'âme le
rêve la capacité de l'âme de s'envoler
du corps
alors nous avons tous cette idée donc
dualiste que l'esprit et le corps ça
n'est pas du tout la même chose ce sont
des choses radicalement différente et
cette idée dualiste et bien elle a été
formalisée par un philosophe qui
s'appelle rené descartes que vous voyez
ici on attribue souvent à rené descartes
des erreurs majeures et c'est devenu
courant de faire du des cartes bashing
si on peut dire de dire ce philosophe
s'est trompé il ya un livre d'un euro
scientifique s'appelle damasio qui a
écrit l'erreur de descartes et je
voudrais d'abord restaurer un tout petit
peu la réputation de notre philosophe
français parce que je pense que c'était
un pionnier extraordinaire du
matérialisme et de la tentative
d'explication des états psychologiques
du cerveau vieillit rené descartes avait
essayé avec les moyens de l'époque était
limité de comprendre comment la vision
l'action la mémoire les veille et le
sommeil résulter des tas de notre
cerveau à l'époque il pensait que
c'était la glande pinéale qui se pencher
d'un côté ils excellent idée c'est de
trouver toutes sortes de mécanismes pour
expliquer ses fonctions et il écrit de
façon extraordinairement moderne la
respiration
la veille le sommeil la réception de la
lumière les sons les odeurs la rétention
de ces idées dans la mémoire et enfin
les mouvements extérieurs de tous les
membres suivent tout naturellement cette
machine de la simple disposition de ses
organes ni plus ni moins que font les
mouvements d'une horloge ou d'un autre
automates de celle de ses contrepoids ou
de sérou vous voyez c'est un
matérialisme absolument extraordinaire
pourquoi est-ce que des cartes est resté
associé à l'idée de dualisme l'idée que
la chose pensante c'est à dire ce qu'il
appelait la rèze cogitant scolytes ans
est différente de la chose matérielle
l'art est externe ça et bien parce qu'il
ne voyait pas il est très honnête et il
ne voyait pas comment on pouvait
expliquer par une machine les
comportements humains les comportements
humains sont d'une extraordinaire
diversité ne pouvons agir de façon très
flexible et ça se voit notamment dans
nos paroles nous sommes pas du tout
semblable aux automates de l'époque on
appuie sur un bouton et on obtient
peut-être un son mais ici chez l'homme
il ya une diversité de comportements qui
était difficile a expliqué à l'époque de
descartes et en fait des cartes était un
grand précurseur et il a fallu attendre
le xxème siècle milieu du xxème siècle
avec
turing avec john von neumann l'arrivée
de l'informatique contemporaine que vous
connaissez qui a permis de comprendre
que oui en fait une machine peut
produire de la parole oui une machine
peut agir et flexibilité
nous avons tous dans les poches des
smartphones qui sont des machines
extraordinaires qui dont on aurait rêvé
des cartes mais qui permet de voir que
l'intelligence n'est plus inaccessible
aux machines vous savez qu'une machine a
battu le meilleur joueur de go mondiale
nous sommes maintenant dominé sur le
plan de l'intelligence par ces machines
mais alors qu'en est il des états
subjectif est ce qu'une machine pour
être consciente et avoir une conscience
subjective et est ce que après tout des
états subjectif de conscience n'échappe
pas complètement à l'étude scientifique
parce que la science essaye d'être
objective alors que là il s'agit d'états
subjectif et bien c'est ça je voudrais
vous montrer aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
ce n'est pas du tout difficile en
réalité d'analyser les états subjectif
du cerveau et je voudrais vous faire
montrer une toute petite expérience
voilà vous regardez attentivement cette
scène ici je vous demande de fixer le
point blanc
l'essai de ne pas bouger votre regard du
point blanc qui est au centre et au bout
d'un certain temps vous allez faire
l'expérience de ce phénomène
parfaitement subjectif les points jaunes
disparaissent est ce que ça marche
parfois ils disparaissent tous en même
temps
parfois l'un d'entre eux ça clignote ça
s'allume ça revient alors c'est
intéressant vous avez tous ce phénomène
subjectif chacun d'entre vous là à un
moment différent mais nous avons tout ce
phénomène il est reproductible on peut
l'analyse en laboratoire
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien il se
passe que votre cerveau prend une
décision il dit s'il ya des points fixes
sur ma rétine sur mon capteurs c'est
sans doute des défauts du capteur et je
ferai mieux d éliminer pour mieux voir
l'image qui a derrière c'est ce que
ferait n'importe quelle machine qui
aurait une salissure sur sa caméra par
exemple c'est ce que fait notre cerveau
c'est une décision
la conscience subjective est le résultat
de calculs non conscient et le plus
objectif possible alors je vous donne un
autre exemple une autre illusion qui
vous montrent que pratiquement n'importe
quelle scène que vous voyez que vous
analysez et le résultat d'un traitement
non conscient et donne lieu à des états
subjectif qu'est ce qui est spécial ici
on dirait une scène tout à fait normal
et un échiquier avait des cases noires
et des cases blanches
il ya rien de particulier jusqu'à ce que
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
sur le plan
objectif ces deux cas sont
rigoureusement identiques elles ont
exactement le même niveau de gris et sur
votre rétine c'est la même chose mais je
reviens à l'aspect subjectif et en une
demi-seconde votre cerveau calcul que
l'une est noire et l'autre et blanches
objectifs identiques subjectif
différents alors qu'est ce qui se passe
ici
et bien en fait voyez un cylindre sur
l'échiquier puis à une zone qui
correspond à son ombre en fait c'est pas
une ombre
c'est une tache sur votre rétine mais
votre cerveau interprète ça comme étant
une ombre et du coup vous donne à voir
la couleur de l'échiquier sans cette
ombre parce que c'est ça qui est
intéressant à percevoir et n'importe
quelle machine qui devrait analyser ces
images et qui essaieraient de déterminer
la couleur de l'échiquier ferait la même
erreur un état subjectif peut être le
résultat d'un calcul objectif alors 3e
illusion qui était plus facile pour nous
analysé en laboratoire c'est ce qu'on
appelle les images subliminales
vous avez ici je vous rappelle un
épisode qui a été un petit peu
scandaleux on peut le dire c'était la
présentation du visage de françois
mitterrand pendant une durée
extraordinairement brève dans le
générique de ce qui s'appelait à
l'époque antenne 2 pendant la campagne
présidentielle
on peut se demander si ça a conduit à
biaiser la décision de tel ou tel vote
en mai tel ou tel électeur mais on sait
maintenant que ses effets sont durée
très brève mais tout de même il
fonctionne on peut en laboratoire
présenter un mot pendant une durée
extraordinairement brève et s'il est
pris en sandwich par d'autres formes on
ne le voit pas on peut le rendre
rigoureusement invisible et ensuite en
rallongeant un tout petit peu le mot en
écartant les masques on peut le rendre
visible à nouveau nous pouvons donc en
laboratoire manipuler à volonté
votre conscience subjective faire
apparaître ou disparaître de votre
conscience
un mot qui est pourtant présent sur
votre rétine alors le dernier ingrédient
de cette science de la conscience
évidemment c'est que muni de toutes ces
manières il y en encore bien d'autres de
manipuler votre conscience
nous pouvons ensuite aller voir dans
votre cerveau et en particulier au
centre neurospin que je dirige dans le
sud de paris
nous disposons de toute une série de
machines qui permettent comme vous le
savez certainement d'aller voir les
états d'activité du cerveau en grands
détails anatomiques avec l'irm
fonctionnelle et puis
le temps avec les potentiels évoqués la
magnétoencéphalographie et même parfois
avec des électrodes qui sont placés
directement dans le cerveau
alors je vous rassure tout de suite je
ne demande pas de volontaire aujourd'hui
pour cette intervention
mais il se trouve qu'il ya des patients
épileptiques qui sont explorées avec des
électrodes dans le cerveau et on peut
s'appuyer sur cette situation clinique
pour faire des recherches
donc qu'est ce qu'on a appris et bien la
première chose que nous avons appris
c'est l'extraordinaire étendue du
traitement non conscient dans le cerveau
nous traitons en permanence les
informations pratiquement chacune des
régions de notre cortex est en train de
traiter l'information de façon non
consciente
vous reconnaissez un visage de façon
inconsciente même sans avoir conscience
de l'avoir perçue si un mot et présentez
vous le lisez inconsciemment vous
accédez à son sens
inconsciemment si son sens est un sens
émotionnel par exemple le mot viol vous
allez activé l'amygdale cérébrale qui
est une région spécialisée dans les
émotions négatives et notamment la peur
vous alles est activée une évaluation de
son sens positif ou négatif si c'est un
nombre vous avez effectué des calculs
inconsciemment vous allez détecter
inconsciemment si ces calculs sont
erronés ou pas et vous allez pouvoir
activer jusqu'à votre cortex moteur sans
conscience et ce ne sont que des
exemples
il ya des dizaines expérience
aujourd'hui qui montrent que le cerveau
fonctionne de façon principale sur un
mode non conscient mais alors vous me
direz qu est ce qui se passe lorsqu'un
mot franchi le seuil de conscience
et bien voilà une des toutes premières
images que nous avons obtenus et qui
vous montre quand même qu'à une énorme
différence
un mot non conscient restent confinés
dans des circuits spécialisés
il est en quelque sorte traitait de
façon automatique par des circuits
spécialisés alors que le mot conscient
lui voyait d'entraîner tout un surcroît
d'activité
ce qu'on a appelé l'embrasement confiant
à une sorte d'embrasement neuronale dans
un espace cérébrale beaucoup plus grand
l'information qui est consciente devient
diffusé à l'échelle de tout le cerveau
et c'est pour ça que nous pouvons agir
lorsque nous sommes conscients de façon
flexible ce qui frappait des cartes nous
pouvons nommer par exemple ce dont nous
sommes conscients
parce que nos circuits cérébraux vont
amener l'information jusqu'au circuit du
langage qui permettent de le nommer et
de manière générale lorsque nous sommes
conscients des informations nous
pourrons l'utiliser de manière
extraordinairement flexible alors cet
embrasement neuronale nous l'avons vu
avec d'autres méthodes dit
amis qu en présentant un mot qui peut
être soit visible soit invisible comme
je vous l'expliquais auparavant en haut
vous avez l'activité cérébrale pour le
moins visible en bas l'activité
cérébrale pour le mot visible si je
démarre ce film vous allez voir que au
départ les choses sont rigoureusement
identiques pendant environ 200 300
millisecondes notre cerveau fait
exactement la même chose de façon
consciente ou non conscient voyez-le
active le pôle occipital la
reconnaissance visuelle de mots se
produit de façon identique mais c'est
seulement dans les étapes plus tardive
que vous allez voir un embrasement
spécifique de la condition consciente
lorsque vous prenez conscience
d'information le cortex frontal va
s'allumer l'information va s'étendre à
ces régions antérieures du cerveau le
cortex frontal
c'est ici 33% à peu près du cerveau
humain une région qui s'est
particulièrement développé dans notre
espèce on peut aller plus loin et
regarder la conscience au niveau d'un
neurone unique et ça c'est absolument
extraordinaire nous avons aujourd'hui
des cas très particuliers de patients
avec l'épilepsie chez lesquels on peut
insérer des électrodes suffisamment fine
pour enregistrer un seul neurones dans
le cerveau humain et ont fait des
découvertes remarquables par exemple
qu'il existe des neurones qui code pour
un concept particulier voyez ici un
neurone qui code pour le concept du wall
trade center avant l'attentât
et vous avez ce neurones qui ne
déchargent cowell trade center et pas à
des dizaines d'autres concepts de
personnes de lieux qui sont différents
et par ailleurs ce neurones ne décharge
que si on prend conscience de
l'information etc si l'information est
présenté de façon extrêmement brève une
image subliminale
il n'y a pas de décharge de ce neurones
et même à durer constante si le patient
dit ah bah là j'ai pas réussi à voir
l'image
le neuro ne va pas décharger il ne
décharge que pour un concept conscient
donc voyez que il faut imaginer que
chacune de nos pensées et le résultat
d'un tel code neuronale nous avons des
populations de neurones sans doute
plusieurs milliers ou millions à chaque
fois qu'ils code chacune de nos pensées
bien sûr la conscience ça n'est pas
seulement percevoir un objet dans le
monde extérieur lorsqu'on est conscient
on continue d'être conscient lorsqu'on
est par exemple dans le noir qui a plus
de stimulation particulière mais nos
pensées continue de se dérouler sur un
mode conscient et là encore l'imagerie
cérébrale l'a montré de façon très
claire
le cerveau effectivement des rôles
lorsqu'il est conscient tout une série
d'états d'activités qui ne cesse de
changer en permanence et qui
correspondent dans une grande mesure au
contenu de nos pensées consciente
on peut analyser ces états d'activité
cérébrale mais qui changent en
permanence et on peut d'une part les
décoder avec des méthodes de machine
learning d'apprentissage automatique et
voir que l'on peut décoder des états
conscient et non conscient et on peut
même aller plus loin et on peut
commencer à décoder le contenu
particulier de la conscience si on
réveille une personne par exemple alors
qu'elle était en sommeil paradoxal se
réveille et on lui demandait ce que dans
votre rêve
il y avait un visage ou pas et dont on
peut prédire s'il y avait un visage ou
pas dans le rêve
en décodant l'activité cérébrale dans
les régions qui s'occupe des visages
dans le cerveau donc vous voyez qu'on
commence à voir une correspondance
remarquable qu'on peut inverser par
décodage entre état d'activités
cérébraux et états mentaux rapportés par
le sujet où va cette science est bien un
de ses domaines d'application le plus
important ce sont les applications
cliniques
vous savez que malheureusement on peut
tous perdre la conscience soit parce que
on s'endort le soir et on perd notre
conscience soit parce qu'on est
anesthésié et la compréhension de
l'anesthésié est un objectif important
mais aussi parce qu'on a un accident de
voiture un accident vasculaire
notre cerveau est lésé et vous savez que
certaines personnes vont trouver dans le
coma vont tomber dans ce qu'on appelle
un état végétatif qui est peut-être pire
encore c'est à dire le cerveau continue
de s'endormir et de s'éveiller mais
pendant la journée
la personne ne répond plus on n'arrive
plus à communiquer avec elle elle ne
bouge plus volontairement et parfois au
bout de quelques semaines ce qui était
rim ont fini par s'apercevoir qu'en fait
elle est toujours consciente elle bad la
paupière et si on analyse ce battement
de la paupière
on peut voir qu'il ya quelqu'un à
l'intérieur quelqu'un qui peut être
parfois parfaitement conscient comme
l'était jean dominique bauby lorsqu'il a
écrit ce roman absolument extraordinaire
cette histoire de sa vie
cette biographie le scaphandre et le
papillon que vous avez peut-être lui qui
est entièrement dicté en battant de la
paupière
alors comment faire la différence entre
un patient inconscient et un patient
dont conscients parfois il ya des
patients qui n'ont même plus le
battement de paupières sont ils encore
conscient et bien
le domaine a été révolutionnée lorsque
nous avons vu que effectivement pouvait
utiliser l'imagerie cérébrale pour faire
la différence
ici c'est une des toutes premières
études chez une patiente qui était en
état végétatif apparent sauf que
lorsqu'on lui demande d'imaginer qu'elle
joue au tennis ou d'imaginer qu'elle se
promène dans son appartement
et bien elle a d état d'activités qui
sont identiques à ceux d'un sujet normal
conscient elle est certainement
consciente de la même manière on peut
regarder un film de hitchcock et voir
que les moments de suspense sont des
moments où le cerveau cet espace de
travail globale qui permet la conscience
sont activés au moment où on est rivé
par l'action dans le film eh bien on
peut mesurer donc un état d'activités
consciente et chez certains patients on
le voit également
on a encore beaucoup d'autres
possibilités on peut stimuler le cerveau
et regarder jusqu'à quelle profondeur va
se propager
l'activité si elle se propage loin ça
veut dire qu'un état réverbérant de
conscience de la part du sujet et dans
mon laboratoire on regarde les échanges
d'informations entre régions cérébrales
distante et on voit que ces échanges
d'informations sur beaucoup plus riches
lorsque la personne est consciente que
lorsqu elle ne l'est pas et c'est une
autre manière de diagnostiquer la
conscience et vous avez peut-être vu
dans les médias récemment il devient
possible non seulement de mesurer
diagnostiqués mais aussi de stimuler la
conscience avec des électrodes profondes
comme on le fait dans le parkinson
on va pouvoir le faire chez les patients
avec troubles de la conscience et
restaurer ou en tout cas faciliter la
restauration de la conscience chez
certains d'entre eux lorsque le cortex
n'est pas trop endommagé
alors voilà cette histoire donc des
sciences de la conscience je crois que
il faut accepter que chacun de nos états
mentaux même les plus intimes m'aimait
plus émouvant sont le résultat de
calculs de notre cerveau et sans n'en
est pas moins intéressant je suis mon
cerveau il faut accepter cette idée là
mais il ya une deuxième idée aussi
derrière cet exposé c'est que la boîte
crânienne s'ouvre elle devient visible
l'imagerie cérébrale rend visible des
états mentaux qui jusqu'à présent
étaient cachés est ce qu'il faut s'en
inquiéter
peut-être mais je pense que c'est aussi
une opportunité absolument
extraordinaire de se comprendre soi-même
d'analyser les origines de nos
comportements et de progresser
collectivement dans ce domaine savait
que l'une des
idée de la philosophie grecque la plus
importante peut-être c'était connais toi
toi même et je pense que si socrate et
platon revenait aujourd'hui
eh bien il se précipiteraient vers les
neurosciences et direct connais toi toi
même ça veut dire apprend à connaître
ton propre cerveau merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
ap